hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast allowing your skin
biosensing programmable temporary
tattoos presented by Carlos all games
founder and CEO of logic egg
I am Marjorie poorest of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labrys Watrous is a leading scientific
social networking website from producer
of educational venture virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
then type your question into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
between icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Hollis okey I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You Marge
and thank you to Larry for inviting us
to give this talk this is a very short
talk by the way we are in the process of
making of a bigger announcement later
this year and until then this is more of
a teaser but I hope you will find it
interesting so today you you may agree
with me that the market for health
monitoring devices is highly fragmented
and many critical sensors are not
available or only exist in a laboratory
settings you know what a flip-top exists
commercially tends to be bulky expensive
and invariably requires the use of
additional electronic devices always
made for a multi sensing wearable
variance that is impractical or
unaffordable for many people yes many
people want to learn more about their
bodies to live a healthier and longer
life that's exactly the challenge that
we're trying to address that and logic
Inc if you move to the next slide in a
way we're looking to continue to expand
the current state of health monitoring
we add logic and growth creating local
friction design oriented wearable
platform will we think of ourselves as
building a future where people
experience sensing technology every day
privately or socially these being both a
combat of health awareness but also of
self expressions we think that this
approach allows us to capture a
significantly larger market and and
users Emma graphic when compared to the
current state of wearable sensing
devices so whatever we do so we make
electronic free world that are
non-invasive and change in chase or
color to alert you of a condition of
interest in your body or in the
surrounding environment let me move to
the next slide the applications that one
one can derive from the sensing of sweat
skin volatiles in my River
or from the surrounding environment are
really limitless as the number of
sensors and users grow
we also imagine being able to produce a
high degree of personalization targeting
conditions and ventures based on a
person's unique physiology or lifestyle
choices and again the surrounding
environment this slide just gives you a
small sample of thousands of molecules
and conditions that can be sent from
one's body or the surrounding
environment in a way we're trying to
create where you know our long-term
vision is about creating this body /
world oil platform almost like a second
skin as you well so without sharing too
much at this point I'll except I'm one
of the world will sensors that we
develop in the past is if the video
should play out in a second let's see if
this work shows this work was done in
the summer of 2015
and it was done in great part by one of
our founding advisors called the Nino -
the professor at Columbia right now and
at that time he was working full-time
with our company at that time called
bio-ink so this video shows the
progression of the development of the
first of what we think is the first
electronic three wearable audible
vice-minister to give you a bit of
background about the relevance of this
work also close the portal meaning
preventable cause of death in the United
States roughly you know 20% of college
students meet the criteria for an
alcohol use disorder this is all money
from NIH so it's in in a way is
important to come up with solutions that
are not just about
you know nibbling police officers or
court orders to how your scrutiny over
people who already have the trash hole
and can are being you know quote but
instead and this is in general part of
our vision at logic it's all about
empowering people before something
happens
making them more aware of the impact of
their lifestyle choices in their health
in general as they try to again live a
healthier life moving forward so that's
what we're trying to do with this
wearable at that time it was a proof of
concept that we submitted to NIH the
videocast very quickly but I can say
roughly that initially up late I don't
know if I can play it again we'll just
move back and forth and then this should
play again so in a strip show
recalibration of the heath competitions
to show a colorimetric readout when it
goes through alcohol concentrations well
below GUI levels and in between the
concentration song in your own sweat
when you drink later shows the calories
I think composition directly in the skin
in later and a temporary century form
factor as I mentioned before the percent
was submitted to NIH for the first war
we'll also pull I was in for challenge a
they tested invalidated the prototype
definitely means that somebody has to
get drunk at NIH and we want an
honorable mention being again the only
electronic screen submission everybody
else was focused on and with trying to
dependent devices so we're really happy
about this work is not our first caller
to market it's not about what we're
going to make a big announcement layer
this year but it's going to do some
ideas it's worked out what's published
that's why we're all for sharing this
and this you know published by NIH in
terms of being one of the finalists
and I hope that gives you a little bit
of an insight about one division of what
logic things aims to achieve and two as
a very specific example of politics
could look like in the future I'll leave
you with this last line about our vision
and and thank you so much for your time
Thank You Carlos for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button we're after as many of
your questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is how do
these centers work yeah so we can't say
too much about how they work but well at
this point at least what we can say is
that these are non-invasive sensors in
we use a number of methods based on our
team's expertise whether it is through
the use of you know responsive chemicals
or cell-free enzyme systems or all
including wholesale biosensors as well
depending on what type of target were
working with right now in America of
course can they connect to a phone yeah
we can ask that a lot if even though
we're saying that these are electronic
three wearable you know at the same time
we are building an app that it's not a
requirement for people to use but it
provides an enhanced experience for
those who want to and that's really
important like we don't want to make it
a requirement and then have people who
are normally more tech savvy
like to do those things to be an
intersection with people who care off
with with what's going on in their body
in general or the environment we think
we want to reach out your wiring is a
demographic beyond you know tech savvy
users who like to have liked me
gadgets draft to their bodies 24 by 7 so
again there is an app but it's optional
keeping adoption friction love are these
permanent tattoos no not at all these
are temporary have to like devices so
there is strictly speaking they're not
temporary tattoo but they can look like
men and there's definitely completely
non-invasive there no much for needles
there's there's nothing that is going
for your skin at all along getting last
they can laugh a few a few days you know
four to five days I have one with me
right now and then on for four days so
far so far so good
over water please yes they are and also
justify quite a little bit on how long
they last
it's uh even though they can last that
long it's more about how we design them
so that they make sense within you know
a day versus three days versus more so
technically we can make them last more
than what we're designing for I would
like to once again thank college
audience for this presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots from making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go Alana let everyone know
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 25th
2017 you'll receive an email from labret
Landing and Linda's webcast will be
available for replay
to share that investment with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye